[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la française les plus marquants de la
fin des années 90
[Musique]
grâce à leur groove et à leur style
rnbitable et poétique lover ont réussi à
placer deux albums et ses singles au top
des chartes françaises en seulement 3
ans le groupe composé de quatre copains
de lycées de Noisy-le-Grand qui s'est
fait connaître en gagnant grimpe de
stars en 1997 à part la suite coup du
moins de succès et Jane l'un des membres
de la bande a poursuivi sa carrière en
rejoignant un autre groupe classe Vegas
en 2017 le chanteur sera l'affiche d'une
autre comédie musicale Notre Dame de
Paris qui connaîtra un immense succès
Jane notre invité ce soir moi je suis le
dernier à être entré dans le groupe
j'allais entraînement et puis je les ai
rencontré ils m'ont dit tiens toi tu as
une tête de chanteur ah bon mais je sais
pas ce que c'est une tête de chanteurs
en fait les mecs sont mis à chanter
devant moi ils m'ont dit mais tu chantes
un peu je dis ils m'ont dit ouais j'ai
un producteur ça m'intéresse j'ai vu les
sous tu vois donc j'ai commencé à
chanter tu vois
comme ça jusqu'à quel endroit tu claques
très bien les doigts il y avait 17 ans
que ça a cartonné et le groupe après
prennent des GO enfin le groupe c'est
séparé vous avez arrêté de vous voir
c'est pourquoi vous séparez pas du tout
c'est on passe tellement de temps
ensemble si on n'est pas habitué moi
j'étais encore au lycée tout va super
vite tu as beaucoup de de gens autour il
y a eu un moment donné des des des
choses qui sont passées où il y en avait
un qui écrivait un peu plus que d'autres
qui étaient Rudy et et à un moment donné
il a il a signé son album solo et en
même temps il y avait un manager qui
essaie plus ou moins de manipuler pour
saisir pas c'est le mec qui ramène le
plus d'oseille donc c'est bien que je
regarde sous mon aile nous on avait
appris qu'il avait signé en fait c'était
que des choses il y a de l'argent
derrière tout ça franchement tout était
bien établi c'est-à-dire que tu avais
Rudy qui était vraiment la tête pensante
qui avait fait le conservatoire et qui
était vraiment le moi c'est le mec qui
m'a appris à chanter et vous voyez
encore aujourd'hui tous ah non là on est
là on est on est tous les frères là on
est vraiment on est retourné ensemble là
on est vraiment ensemble on prépare son
nouveau on est sur un nouveau projet
gros projet
c'est une danseuse juste les salaires
alors les salaires c'est vrai qu'ils ont
grossièrement baissé après il faut dire
que l'émission ce que tu vas dire il y a
des gens qui gagnent 1000 balles mais
vas-y non mais évidemment ça reste des
salaires exorbitants voilà quelqu'un
lambda mais c'est vrai que Zazie qui
touchait entre 800 et 900000 € quand
elle était là dans les premières saisons
elle va passer aux alentours de 500
ensuite Amel Bent elle est aux alentours
de 300000 elle va passer à 200000 et
Vianney et Bigflo et Oli ils sont aux
alentours de 150000 c'est les plus
faibles cachés historiques de l'histoire
de The Voice mais en même temps le coup
de production a baissé c'était environ
un million d'euros par prime dans les
premières saisons et où on est
aujourd'hui on est aux alentours
pardonne de 750 000 € merci
Miss
USA qui a été élu Miss Univers le 15
janvier dernier la plus belle femme
voilà du monde lors des élections Miss
Univers vous avez Miss Univers et Miss
Monde
[Applaudissements]
elle est jolie elle est très belle mais
ce qui est très amusante et qui fait le
tour des réseaux sociaux c'est qu'elles
doivent chacune arriver et crier leur
pays voilà sauf qu'il y en a une elle
avait un mot à dire c'était l'année
dernière elle a chié et depuis bah ça
fait le tour et tout le monde se moque
d'elle c'est le pays qui a annoncé
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis né ainsi je me suis construit je
me suis construit comme ça j'ai une
finitude j'ai appris comme ça il a pas
fallu réapprendre
et c'est une histoire de télé il semble
très bien on forme un groupe qui
s'appelle hellinkup Otis Matt Pokora et
toi et là plein de types qui cartonne je
crois notre étoile et tout ça ça part la
tournez pas les unités machin et là tu
utilises c'est bon je suis arrivé
maintenant pokora s'en va fais une
carrière solo ça cartonne pour lui et
pour toi les maisons de disques prennent
un peu moins bref ça prend pas alors que
tu chantes bien quelle explication j'en
sais rien comment tu le vis
au début c'est un peu compliqué donc je
le cache pas j'aimais bien la variété
donc je suis allé moi enregistrer de mon
côté et à chaque fois que j'en ai des
titres moins chez M6 interaction et chez
Universal je sentais que c'était pas la
priorité donc quand tu sens que tu es
pas la priorité que tu balances un
premier titre un deuxième titre un
troisième tu arrives à 40 j'en ai 40 à
la maison je le voyais et je sentais que
j'étais pas la priorité un moment donné
tu es fatigué tu es puisé et là tu
commences à partir en dépression ce que
j'ai fait combien ça t'avait rapporté
tout ça les chansons les links 70000
euros en tout et pour tout donc une fois
que tu as épuisé tout ton argent tu es
dans un studio tu as plus d'argent on
s'intéresse pas à toi et là c'est
dépression bah ouais c'est la dépression
en fait si tu fais le calcul on donne 70
000 euros on dit ça s'arrête toujours au
lendemain donc tu dois vivre avec ça et
on t'impose de pas prendre le métro
parce que on va faire des singles
prochainement on t'impose de prendre le
taxi on t'impose d'avoir un train de vie
qui va en adéquation avec la célébrité
et on te dit voilà il faut que tu vois
ça mais en fait tu fais le calcul 70 000
€ sur 2 ans ça fait 3500 euros par mois
et tu dois vivre avec ça en fait et on
dit ne fais pas autre chose que ça même
maintenant Cora lui-même dire pardon
mais on n'était pas pote on a créé un
groupe tout ça c'est pour ça qu'on se
voit plus c'était un truc de casting
voulu en voulez pas de de pas le en fait
il l'a dit dans une émission on a porté
ça m'a un peu choqué
de dire en fait ça a été que 9 mois de
ma vie et quelque part
rien pour moi c'est juste le tremplin si
on fait pas un numéro 1 parce que faut
pas se mentir tout le monde dit les
Linkup ça a été très court ça a été 750
000 disques vendu j'ai un triple disque
d'or chez moi on a fait toutes les
émissions possibles et imaginables que
ce soit M6 TF1 et Hit Machine tu peux
pas dire ça ne m'a pas